the most important thing is that you
stay with the task and remain active
don't put pressure on yourself don't
force yourself to do activities that you
don't like to do don't do things that
are likely to make you run out of energy
vary the activities vary studying hard
with relaxation by all means find
someone if you can find someone to talk
to in the language and that it if it's a
low stress environment that's all good
so I think we don't all have the same
level of energy we should all be mixing
in Period of relaxation we shouldn't be
afraid either to relax or to study
another language we should apply the
level of energy that we have and do
things that either require less energy
or give us a sense of energy and part of
that is to give yourself credit for what
you're doing and mainly that means give
yourself credit for being active
remaining active in learning the
language